good morning afternoon everybody
the president will make a statement on
the digital package which was just
adopted by the college yes thank you so
much indeed today the college adopted a
whole package on our digital strategy it
is the white book for artificial
intelligence and the data strategy we do
have in Europe a long history of
technological success and innovation we
have seen businesses we have a very
strong industry and in Europe we are
caring very much for individual rights
and our values and the digital strategy
we put forward today is connecting all
these dots and putting it into a concept
we want the digital transformation to
power our economy and we want to find
European solutions in the digital age so
let me start with artificial
intelligence we all know that artificial
intelligence can do amazing things and I
think we don't talk enough about what
artificial intelligence is able to do to
improve our daily lives for example if
we look at the healthcare sector
we know that when use already now
artificial intelligence for for example
better diagnosis and earlier diagnosis
and better and earlier diagnosis are
crucial when you treat for example
cancer or we do would use robots for
precision surgery but artificial
intelligence is also key for us when we
want to reach our goal to be climate
neutral in 2015 just think of precision
farming precision farming AI driven
enables us to reduce pesticides
enables us to reduce fertilizers for
example or if you think of smart eating
smart heating AI driven again is saving
millions and millions of tons of oil for
example and therefore reducing the co2
footprint hey I will not only improve
our daily lives but Europe is already
leading in AI Europe has a pole position
and we should also be aware of that we
produce 25% of all industrial robots for
example and if you look at our
manufacturers every second of them is
using already today at least one AI
application and if you look at the
science field the research field you see
when you look at the articles that are
published the most articles are
published from the European science
community so we have a pole position in
AI but of course we are aware of the
fact things are moving on so fast that
we have to do more and therefore we want
to boost European artificial
intelligence by attracting more than 20
billion euros per year for the next
decade artificial intelligence is about
big data data data and again data and we
all know that the more data we have the
smarter our algorithms this is a very
simple equation and therefore it is so
important to have access to data that
are out there this is why we want to
give our businesses but also our
researchers and the public services
better access to data we all know that
we're generating by the day data and
data again today for example the global
amount of data that is produced when you
look five years ahead from now this
amount of data will be only produced by
Europe so we have a huge amount of data
that is collected often just by accident
and we want to give better access to of
Europeans to these data
that are out there Europe has a good
advantage in the quality of data we have
because we have a broad economic
diversity with our small and medium
enterprises with what we call meter
stunts with our industry it's a very
diverse and rich landscape and therefore
the data that are collected in Europe on
a daily basis are very diverse and rich
to industry data commercial data data
from factories machines cars weather
stations you just name it it is a fact
that the majority of data we collect
today are never ever used even once and
this is not at all sustainable in these
data we collect that are out there lies
an enormous amount of precious ideas
potential innovation untapped potential
we have to unleash and therefore we
follow the principle that you have to
offer in Europe we have to offer data
spaces where you can not only store your
data but also share with others and
therefore we want to create European
data spaces where businesses governments
and researchers cannot only store their
data but also have access to other data
they need for their innovation research
is a classical thing of course you need
to store your data but it's of utmost
importance and interest for researchers
to access the data of other researchers
to go into new fields and to push
forward innovation to create these
European Union data spaces and cloud
infrastructure we want to trigger
investment of four to six billion euros
the value of the data economy is
enormous in the European Union it is 300
billion right away this is 2.4 percent
of the gross domestic product this is
today
in five years it will be estimated three
times as much so you see the speed at
which this is growing and this also
means creating jobs today we have 5.7
million jobs in five years these will
estimated be about eleven million jobs
therefore our focus in the data strategy
and in the white book for AI is also
strongly on skills because we need those
skills to fill the jobs I was just
talking about there is a good story to
tell about AI in Europe data in Europe
but of course with every good part
there's also the part of the risks and
in his widely quoted book 24:21 lessons
for the 21st century of you were a newer
Harare he said and i want to quote that
because it's very nice humans were
always far better at inventing tools
then using them wisely and of quote
so these so-called new tools we want
citizens to trust the new technology and
technology is always neutral it depends
on what we make with it
and therefore we want the application of
these new technologies to deserve the
trust of our citizens this is why we are
promoting a responsible human centric
approach to artificial intelligence we
will be particularly careful with
sectors where essential human interests
and rights are at stake this is for
example recruitment this is for example
the health care sector but it is also
transferred it is police and law
enforcement and you can think about
other fields too artificial intelligence
must serve people and therefore
artificial intelligence must always
comply with people's rights this is why
a person must always be in control of
critical decisions
and so-called high-risk AI this is AI
that potentially interferes with
people's rights have to be tested and
certified before they reach our single
market this is a very simple question
because we do it just the same way with
for example cars or chemicals or
cosmetics or toys they have to be tested
and certified before they enter the
single market and there's a second point
in it we have to make sure that the data
used is free of any bias so as I said
initially the algorithm is as smart as
the data with the data you feed them so
if you feed an algorithm with data for
example that is that are mainly produced
in a field where you have men in the
medical sector well a a I driven
therapeutic or diagnostic instrument
will not be fit for purpose if you have
a population where you have women that
are treated with these applications
therefore to have non biased data is of
utmost importance and we have to be very
vigilant in this field over all today's
message is that artificial intelligence
is a huge opportunity in Europe for
Europe we do have a lot but we have to
unleash this potential that is out there
we want this innovation in Europe we
want to encourage our businesses
researchers the innovators the
entrepreneurs to develop artificial
intelligence and we want to encourage
our citizens to feel confident to use it
in Europe basically we do have all what
we need but we have to unleash this
potential thank you thank you very much
president I will now invite you to join
the press conference on the digital
package by the executive vice president
Steyr and Commissioner Bratton which
will take place in the main Prescott
thank you thank you
[Music]